the left has spent the last week
suggesting that democracy in america is
in danger and it's in danger because of
those evil republicans and their
willingness to throw out votes and
overthrow election processes ezra klein
has an entire article in the new york
times talking about the evils of
republicans his book his piece is titled
steve bannon is on to something why
because steve bannon has talked about
the fact that republicans need to do
politics locally
so ezra klein says there are people for
the democrats working on a plan b
this week i half-jokingly asked ben
wickler the chairman of the wisconsin
democratic party what it felt to be like
on the front lines of protecting
american democracy
he replied to dead serious by telling me
what it was like he spends his days
obsessing over mayoral races in twenty
thousand person towns because those
mayors appoint the city clerks who
decide whether to pull the drop boxes
for mail-in ballots and small changes to
electoral administration could be the
difference between winning senator ron
johnson's seat in 2022 and having a
chance at democracy reform and losing
the race and the senate wickler is
organizing volunteers to staff phone
banks to recruit people who believe in
democracy to serve as municipal poll
workers because steve bannon has made it
his mission to recruit people who don't
believe in democracy to serve as
municipal poll workers
and then ezra klein says that the right
is suddenly very good at local politics
which is kind of shocking considering
that the right has been terrible at
local politics for at least two
generations and probably longer
in any case notice how ezra klein
characterizes this if you are a
democratic mayoral candidate and you
want to put drop boxes which are
inherently less verifiable than for
example pulling boots if you want to do
that this makes you pro-democracy if you
don't want the drop boxes because you
fear that those are coveted temporary
installations that should go away so you
should actually have to go in and
register to vote you should actually
have to show your id for example this
means that you are bad and the left
wants to broaden out the number of
people who can vote and they want to get
rid of a lot of the voter verification
methods that republicans have been
pursuing
ezra klein says the republicans are
trying to suppress the vote voter
suppression is having is happening at
every level of government here in
georgia says representative nikima
williams who chairs the georgia
democratic party we have 159 counties
and so 150 159 different ways boards of
elections are elected and elections are
carried out so you have 159 different
leaders who control election
administration in the state we've seen
those boards restrict access by changing
the number of ballot boxes often our
black members on these boards are being
pushed out well i mean you'd have to
show that they're being pushed out
because they're black and not just
because they disagree with you that all
the kovit coveted pandemic
procedures which were supposed to be
temporary are now being gotten rid of
and that that's somehow some sort of
horrible thing for democracy again none
of these things the democrats are now
talking about is deeply necessary for
the business of democracy or present in
2008 when barack obama swamped the
ballot boxes and won a blowout election
and then won re-election in 2012. none
of this stuff existed
but according to ezra klein we have to
rig the election so they don't rigged
the elections is basically the idea this
is how much we care about democracy is
that we need to put in place all these
procedures that are less verifiable
so he he quotes a couple of particular
cases he says gabriela cesares kelly was
a member of the tejano odom nation
agreed to staff a voting registration
booth at a community college where she
worked in pima county arizona she was
stunned to hear the stories of her
students we keep blaming students for
not participating but it's really
complicated to get registered to vote if
you don't have a license the nearest dmv
is an hour and a half away and you don't
own a car she said well somehow 155
million americans came up with the
ability to vote in the last election
cycle
so instead she decided that she was
going to
work on specifically following up with
specific people so for example the
example she gives is that certain people
who work for the county recorder's
office could work with the postmaster's
office to put registration forms in
tribal postal offices or not when it
called to voters to vote or verify a
ballot and heard an answering machine in
spanish it could follow up in spanish or
not
well i mean that works in reverse as
well if you're specifically only calling
up people who have a
an answering machine in spanish and then
you only follow up with those people it
could work that way too like again
at a certain point you're going to have
to assume that the average comes out in
the wash you have some
board of election advisers or democrats
some who are republicans and it mainly
comes out in the wash but this is why
it's so amazing to hear the left
complain that the right is undermining
elections while they consistently
undermine the veracity of elections if
we don't get our way the election is
corrupt if we if by the way again this
would have happened in 2020 if donald
trump had won the left would have been
the one rioting if
this was the great fear leading up to
the 2020 election
the great fear leading up to 2020 is
that if the donald trump had been
declared winner on november 4th just go
back in time and you'll remember this
and there would be widespread riots
across the united states
january 6th is the best thing ever to
happen to the left because it was a
right-wing riot
but the real worry leading up to january
leading up to november 4th leading up to
the election was that if democrats
didn't get their way they would declare
the election illegitimate and blame the
postmaster general and blame trump for
for rigging the ballot boxes and blame
people like brad raffensberger in
georgia for rigging the thing after all
democrats have been claiming this since
2000 now the giveaway is pretty obvious
here the giveaway is that in new york
city democrats have now made it possible
for one million non-citizens to vote
so if you are worried about democrats
broadening the vote to people who really
should not be voting they're kind of
doing it in broad daylight in new york
city according to breitbart up to one
million non-citizens living in new york
city will have access to the ballot box
after mayor eric adams on sunday
approved legislation by the city council
to automatically become law so in other
words a bunch of people who are not
actually
bound by american law because they're
illegal immigrations
because they're illegal immigrants
a bunch of people who are not paying for
example federal income tax unless they
have stolen a social security number
those folks now get to vote in local
elections in new york city adam said in
a statement i believe new yorkers should
have a say in their government which is
why i have and will continue to support
this important legislation i have a
question what's the limiting principle
why wouldn't democrats nationally think
this applies why wouldn't they be
attempting to get maybe 15 20 million
illegal immigrants in the in the country
currently to just have the vote
and and why is that not some sort of
corruption of the electoral process
we have millions and millions of
americans who are voting based on the
fact that they pay income tax and are
subject to all of the nation's laws and
then you have tens of millions of people
who theoretically the democrats would
want to vote
while they don't pay full federal income
tax for example
eric adams said while i initially had
some concerns i had a productive
dialogue with my colleagues in
government to put those concerns at ease
i believe allowing the legislation to be
enacted is by far the best choice and
look forward to bringing millions more
into the democratic process according to
the left the way that the democratic
process works is that the democratic
process
is all about every single human whether
they ought to vote or not being allowed
to vote
more than a dozen communities across the
united states already allow non-citizens
to cast ballots in local elections
including 11 towns in maryland and two
in vermont
measure enables non-citizens who have
been lawful permanent residents of the
city for at least 30 days
30 days as well as those authorized to
work in the u.s including so-called
dreamers to help select the city's mayor
city council members borough presidents
comptroller and public advocate you
think all those folks are going to be in
favor of strict immigration law
now the suggestion that democrats are in
favor of allowing a lot of people to
enter the country illegally so they can
shift the voting it's hard to see how
these folks are very much in favor of
american citizens having priority in the
vote when they are literally
prioritizing non-american citizens
voting in local elections
and the idea that shoring up elections
is a high priority to democrats is
obviously untrue
the right has been suggesting now for
months something called a revision of
the electoral count act do you remember
the electoral count act of 1887.
is kind of vague in its specifics it
allowed for a bunch of confusion inside
the right wing particularly in 2020 over
whether the vice president of the united
states could simply reject votes now the
answer was no but the eca is kind of
unclear
according to dan mclaughlin writing for
the national review the eca's current
language represents the chief point of
vulnerability that turned donald trump's
campaign against the 2020 election into
a riot at the capitol last january 6.
the two most alarming aspects of the
aftermath of 2020 were closely related
one was trump's effort to pressure state
governors state legislatures mike pence
and members of congress to reject biden
electors chosen by statewide popular
vote and substitute trump electors
chosen by state legislatures a revised
eca could address this particular danger
and avoid a repeat of last january 6th
in future elections it would do so by
clarifying that the vp cannot
unilaterally reject electors by
precluding states that select electors
by popular vote from refusing after the
fact to recognize electors chosen by
that vote and by raising the vote
thresholds to make objections to
electors and reject state of electors
slates of electors certified by a state
governor right so this could be cleared
up so you would imagine that democrats
would want to support that right i mean
it would prevent things like the
argument that the election was
illegitimate and that you could have
alternative slates of electors created
by state legislatures like they should
be in favor of this right nope kamala
harris came out against it over the
weekend here is vp harris
because it's not a solution to the
problem at hand which is that
right now in the united states of
america we need federal laws
that guarantee
the freedom and right of every american
to have access to the ballot to be able
to vote the john lewis voting rights act
the freedom to vote act addressed that
issue and those are the issues that are
are present and that are imminent and
that are
really dispositive frankly of this
moment in time in terms of whether we
are going to fight for some of the most
important pillars of a democracy such as
the freedom to she's ridiculous okay
these people are ridiculous they clearly
are not interested in the pillars of
democracy they don't even want to reform
the electoral count act to prevent the
kind of arguments that trump was making
post november 4th they don't care about
democracy they want illegal immigrants
to vote and they don't care about
reforming the eca all they want is to
reform the voting procedures to allow
for more people to vote illegally to
allow for the possibility of voter fraud
and to essentially corrupt the voting
procedures across the nation through
things like ballot harvesting that's
what they actually want and if they
don't get their way they say that
democracy is being undermined it just
demonstrates how full of absolute crap
they are
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang